welcome to this video its attention was
like cascade cascade no no name no name
okay so we get that I know he can take
me five now for equality and which is
really a bit anyway I didn't do it let's
keep some more pieces on the board with
night situ oh okay interesting maybe
it's allow me today to take that with
the bishop if he wants to take i also
have to protect that night a little bit
after 95 i want to play b 36 okay not
sure about this one it's not going to
play be fine anytime soon so what now
it's okay and gain some space so I can
play FYE phone all night now Wow no
group group now if I want and I'm going
to do it grab space here so that was
quickly played so f5 is not winning a
piece why not
okay you have to show me maybe there is
some tactic but I don't see it at the
moment of God most of my stuff is
protected more than once you can
probably get like two pawns or something
and it's it's a messy position so for
blitz game there are still things
happening maybe yeah this is how we can
get two pawns okay get the King out of
checks it's almost invariably useful 95
on e6 i have f six and then want to go
f6 myself so f six killer structure that
cannot be bad I know this is hanging
there but ninety three nights you one
night f5 looks immensely attractive I
wonder
I don't need to do it I mean I can't
really do this play this movement it's
nothing particularly wrong with it and
see three edges take ya currently has
really a lot of parts like four pounds
but they they are all not very great I
can take that you get six I probably
want want to do that I just I just have
to break through at some point and this
looks rather strong Bishop h6 is this
killing push-up age six Queen age five
can g7 king queen there to f5
looks like a complete disaster but is it
really a win I mean I can also just take
on you aid Tiki aid
sorry c3 Queen h5 immediately is that
even better Mamie or chick take 18 put
retaining so many interesting
continuations but I don't I don't see a
flat-out win as usual I'm blind Bishop
g5 maybe see to Queen age 5
yeah this is winning for sure come on
let's disappear when the night is also
hanging so I mean plus night h5 and
everything at once yeah I know queen age
54 mate right Queen age 6 is made check
no black resins you just you just didn't
didn't pay attention at this particular
moment playing this immediately enough
to f5 that's Jerry just a piece yeah I
mean I think he has to do this and then
we just have a normal position i think
an interesting position this eve or f
for business is some aggressive but it's
also know my own structures is kind of
rica sh so it's not exactly a one-sided
keep b5 and I'm winning this piece now
King edge to s routine move 95 here now
I think well f6 it just looks writing to
play that aggressive move Queen age five
is also good now but that cannot be bad
ready the engine is on a whopping + 6 +
GX Teague's and Bishop g5 is the best
move okay I didn't see a win here I mean
there probably is one I didn't see you
made check he I didn't see a maid look
be 7s the mate okay now I didn't see
that one I was thinking this this and I
didn't see that this sat in the position
I didn't see the open be file here yeah
this is jacked
make very quick now I didn't see that
you can come there but Bishop g5 is is
given by the engine as plus what 12 they
are probably it will find a mate
somewhere here it is medium queen age
five year and it's a frost made now he
cannot defend against this attack with
all the pieces okay well thanks for
watching